anybody else think about what would be
behind their door the god complex I'm
not even gonna be around Bush this one's
really good there's so much I like about
this episode I love the concept I love
the location
I think the monsters really neat I think
the supporting cast is really solid I
think the central conceit behind what is
going on and the way they they deal with
it is really cool I think the note that
goes on with Amy Rory and the doctor at
the end is really good I just think this
thing top to bottom is it's just aces I
mean I'll just get out of the way
because I may not even remember to
mention it later about the only thing
that I would maybe bring up is that the
Minotaur as a visual monster they were
kind of wise to hide it for a lot of it
it works well enough it gets the job
done it's not amazing and it's also kind
of a slightly obvious way to go you know
the the the corridors of a hotel or like
a labyrinth what's in a labyrinth a
Minotaur oh that's a little obvious and
also the fact that the doctor's room was
room 11 somebody thought that was clever
it's not but like other than that
honestly oh this is so good and like the
mystery and unraveling how this works
what goes on there's a there's a great
sense of dread about it especially
because like for so long we don't quite
know how this works like we kind to get
it they see something and then they're
scared of it but then they become less
scared of and they start praising this
thing that then kills them but then by
that time they want
like that's just a scary of trajectory
especially if you don't understand why
it's happening it's really cool and the
doctor gets some really awesome like
little moments at the front end he's
he's got his his bouncy energy you know
when he gets told that there are things
in the rooms things hello I love things
ask anyone you know and then you know
the look on his face at times that when
things start going south when Rita goes
or just the way you knew how your
feelings for the alien guy just sort of
go back and forth because like initially
like it's it's almost kind of funny how
he comes from this race from this planet
that is the most conquered planet ever
and like his first instinct everything
is just to surrender like that's kind of
a funny idea but then like you're coming
you feel sad for him about your boy
that's a little it's kind of a rough way
to live isn't it and then when you
realize how scheming he could be you
start to be like oh and then it also
pulls a bit what boys are the damned
pulls which is having a guy who you
don't really like survive the whole
thing because neither the audience nor
the doctor gets to pick who lives
sometimes the people you like her gonna
die and like Rita and Rita was great and
she was smart and she had a great
rapport with Smith and even though she
only appears in this one episode you
feel the loss when you realize she's
gonna die and ami the the idea that what
scared her the most was herself as a
child waiting for him and which makes
perfect sense to like I've really I
again I think I've said this I've always
liked Amy I don't think I've ever not
had an appreciation for Amy but
revisiting this has really up to my how
impressive I feel she is in terms of
both the performance and like just how
she's constructed as a character Moffat
seemed
to really get a me as a character and
even though she maybe has some of them
for lack of a better term Moffat isms
that I think some people tend to
criticize about his female characters
everything about her feels so rooted in
a well understood and fully fleshed out
character that I think it all works even
if some of these are traits and tropes
he tends to use a lot they're all
justified here with her and it it just
fits so well and she has these terrific
little quiet moments you know of her be
scared of her wondering what's gonna
happen and the oh man just that the
atmosphere of this thing cuz yeah hotel
lobbies and then the corridors like how
this how much the same they are and
especially when sometimes they wind
around and you're not even sure why yeah
it's a little unsettling it's a great
place to plunk them down and get them
stuck and I'm sure in some ways it was a
cost-cutting measure because they
probably only had to create like two
bits of corridor and just shoot it from
different angles over and over again who
cares it works
they played into it with the with the
script and with the concept and the idea
it's just so good it's so well
progressed and and I like that we come
in and we've got this group of people
who have already kind of been dealing
with it for a little bit so we don't
have to go through like just raw we have
no idea what's going on where they
actually say oh well we tied up this guy
cuz he's acting weird and the doctor
gets to just jump right into seeing
somebody being possessed and so we get
it up front as opposed to if the doctor
and the companions have been trapped in
there at the same starting time as
everybody else instead they get kind of
a little bit of caught up on everything
and we get to hit the ground really
running while still having it just
gradually unfold over time as we start
to wrap our heads around what the heck
is going on and I love the end I love
the end of the doctor dropping
off Amy and Rory and the thing is this
isn't the first time he's ever dropped
them off he dropped them off between
good man goes to war and let's kill
Hitler and we know that because they had
to do the crop circle to get his
attention
and even as the series opened you know
there was a stretch where they were home
and he was you know kind of trying to
get their attention a little bit but
there's something different about this
time when he drops them off there's
something about the choice this time
it's not just stay here while you go
take care of something it's please have
a life besides me and that in a lot of
ways is a big step for him to take and I
think it is especially poignant with the
fact that this episode comes immediately
after the girl who waited back-to-back
these episodes really complement each
other in terms of the dynamic of the
doctor Amy and Rory in terms of the
doctor really seeing and properly
appreciating the damage that being with
him can do and having a moment where he
steps back because the doctor can be
very selfish not just this doctor most
incarnations of the doctor are capable
of being quite selfish and you know when
it comes to relationships and for him to
take that moment and basically decide I
I need to drop you off here so the Hat I
don't hurt you for at least a little bit
it's a big step for him and it doesn't
feel like the kind of self torment that
say Tennant
did after after Donna or even arguably
after rose because you know he did this
whole no I'm just traveling in my own
just me just me and they very much felt
like like he was trying to punish
himself for what happened to Rose and it
feels a bit more this time like he is
doing the hard thing now so that the
worse thing later maybe won't happen
this time or at the very least he won't
feel like their entire life was their
entire lives were tied up in him and
they had something that was just theirs
and I think I'm not sure he could have
come to this kind of decision and taking
this kind of action with any single
companion I think it kind of had to be
Amy and Rory together he had to see them
together he had to realize the kind of
life that they as a couple might be able
to have without him plus of course also
we are taking steps towards him because
at this point he is you know seen when
he's supposed to die the circumstances
under which he's supposed to die so he's
also sort of slowly marching towards his
own death so he in the audience things
at this point so that's in the mix as
well that's part of it but there really
is something about that goodbye that
just feels right it's not it doesn't
quite have the finality of like a true
this is it but at the same time it it's
not just a oh well yeah I'll be I'll be
back on Tuesday it really hits the sweet
spot of picking up the melancholy and
the gravity of him dropping off and
leaving without them under the
circumstances that he does I really like
I really like this episode this episode
overall is just terrific the god complex
Yuri watched it lately what did you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are
let me down the comments let's talk
about it there's all the usual stuff
like subscribe support me on patreon I
above PayPal tip jar links for those are
down in the description but you don't
have to do any of that if you don't want
because at the end of the day you're the
council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is it your
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]